now with exclusive reaction to biden's
first press conference
is former president donald j trump mr
president thank you very much for
joining us tonight
um joe biden is brazenly stonewalling as
you could see in that press conference
requests for access to these facilities
and as you heard he has no idea when
access will be granted
what's going on here and would you get
away with this
no i wouldn't and we had the border the
most secure they say in 20 years but
really i think
from the beginning it's never been like
this we built almost 500 miles of wall
and it was new wall you know they like
to say renovation
the renovation was we knocked down the
old wall and we built a new wall and
then they say
they call it a renovation but this was
new wall
and and incredible wall that was
you know really did a job in addition to
that mexico worked great with us
we had a tremendous relationship and me
with the president who's a tremendous
person and they gave us 28 000 free
28 000 soldiers along our border and
they stopped people from coming in
and what you're doing now and what
you're seeing now is inhumane these
children and people are a tremendous
number of children by the way but
they're living on top of each other
in squalor this is squalor that's why
they won't allow the press to come in we
let the press go in
and we had much smaller numbers frankly
because people couldn't come up
but we let the press come in but they're
living in
very dangerous conditions there's no
testing for
covet 19 as we call it sometimes
sometimes we call it something else
but there's no testing there's no
nothing and
what's going on is just absolutely
insane it's a horrible situation
and everyone that's seen it nobody's
seen worse nobody's seen anything like
it and if you get cameras
inside some of those facilities you
would see children
on top of children and you'd see filth
and you'd see things that you would not
believe possible well i want to i want
to move on to a claim that uh
biden made about your administration's
treatment of the migrant children watch
if an unaccompanied child ends up at the
border we're just going to let them
starve to death and stay on the other
side
no previous administration did that
either except trump
i'm not going to do it he was accusing
you
of starving people who were wanting to
come across the
the rio grande or the border to the
united states
your reaction well first of all it's
just the opposite but by the time we
finished what we were doing
very few people were coming up because
they knew they weren't going to get
through
we stopped catch and release which was a
disaster that's where you catch somebody
take their name
and release them into our country we
stopped that
they were supposed to come back years
later and go to court but nobody ever
comes back and goes to court
and the very biggest thing was we had to
stay in mexico policy
and that means that we wouldn't allow
people to wait in our country
until they were totally checked out
which most of them didn't
get checked out and they would go back
to their own country
if young kids were with parents but a
lot of times they weren't and we would
take care of them but
uh it is what they're doing now is
outrageous
and they should finish the wall if they
finish the wall they'd be able to
have a lot p you know a lot of people
are right now staying in the few
openings we have openings in the wall
that we're going to be closed up
could have been done over the next month
if it weren't for the fact that we got
sued 11 times
many of the suits by congress and people
in congress and democrats
uh we would have had the wallet it was
almost completed
but we would it took two and a half
years to get the final sign-offs from
the
court victories that we had we had great
court victories but
uh they sued us for two and a half years
and they were suing us on the financing
on the
environment on lots of things we won the
lawsuits
and we built almost 500 miles they
should immediately seal it up and finish
it up
and you would see a lot of a lot of good
things happen but
uh nobody realizes exactly what they're
doing mr brother what was your react
what was your just general reaction
to the way biden handled
the uh so-called press conference today
you know he
he read quite a bit from reference notes
um
but he did he did take some questions uh
it was unusual to say the least
well they were strange questions and
they were asked in a very
uh interesting way it was like softballs
like you're throwing softballs up
and it's just a different world it's
nobody's seen anything like it you know
it
you know it better than anybody you
cover it so well and
it's uh it's very sad to watch actually
they're
they're feeding them questions they're
easy questions i noticed peter ducey
didn't get to ask a question today and
there could be no difficult questions uh
and they're ready to rip the microphone
away if somebody did get a little bit
testy
and you know he just looked the whole
thing is ridiculous you know it and so
do i
oh where was that where was there jimmy
costume mr
mr president where was their jim acosta
i mean
you they'd have acosta like in your face
every day and others they don't have
that yeah
but and if jim acosta were there he'd
ask very soft questions it would be a
whole
different thing the democrats are also
yeah the democrats are also saying
that a problem here is that
apparently america is not sending enough
u.s taxpayer dollars to central america
to solve or alleviate this border crisis
here was nancy pelosi today
the president then president had
withdrawn the money that was
allocated for the northern triangle that
was a mistake and we have to restore
that
they withdrew the money to punish those
countries
mr president did you withdraw money from
central america to punish them
absolutely that's right i on that i
agree with her first time in a long time
years that i've agreed with her
we were paying them 500 million dollars
a year
nobody knew what they were doing with
the money and they were sending
criminals to our country you know when
they're sending
people in the caravans as we call them
uh they're not exactly their finest okay
and
more importantly perhaps is that they
wouldn't take it as we would because
isis was
incredible the job they did and border
patrol incredible these are
incredible men and women when we got
somebody
we captured a bad ms-13 or group
we'd bring them back to the country and
they wouldn't take them
and i said what are we doing how much
money do we give them we pay them 500
million dollars a year
i said stop paying the money immediately
we stopped paying
they called the following day they said
we'd love to have
ms-13 come back into our country please
send them immediately
and we will not be sending any more bad
people and we then got along very well
with them so she's absolutely right
they abused us in so many different ways
they wouldn't take
prisoners and murderers back and we
didn't want them in our country
so we'd bring them back they wouldn't
take them i stopped paying
the 500 million dollars that we were
wasting
when giving it to them as soon as i did
that they immediately agreed to take
back everybody
they said it would be a great honor to
take them back please send them
immediately
yeah mr president today nbc news
reporting that the dhs
of course created it was created after 9
11 to protect america from international
terrorism
now they're moving toward what intel
officials are now saying is the new top
threat domestic
violent extremism that includes
apparently surveilling social media one
here's what they mean there's a quote
from the article the idea is to identify
people
who may through their social media
behavior be prone to influence by toxic
messaging
spread by foreign governments terrorists
and domestic extremists
mr president their dhs is going
after people who
maybe your supporters who they believe
are domestic extremists because they say
things like let's take back our
government are you concerned about that
what i'm concerned about is antifa and
blm
and some of the horrible things that we
witnessed over the last
frankly long period of time when they
take over portland and they take over
the courthouse
and they destroy the building you have
to see what they've done to the building
over the years
and just over the last few weeks they've
been having massive
riots and other things in portland and
even the crazy mayor this mayor is just
absolutely
he's a radical left and he can't take it
anymore he's actually said he can't take
it anymore
there you have to see what the streets
of portland look like they've been
burning the city down
and nobody does anything about it and
they don't go after those people
but they go after people that i guess
you'd call them
lean toward the right and they wave
american flags in many cases they're
waving the american flag
and they love our country and those
people they're arresting them by the
dozens but
they don't go after antifa who kill
people
by the way who burn down our cities look
at what they did to seattle
they took over a big partial of land in
seattle a big
a big portion of the city and had i not
gotten the national guard ready to go in
we were going in the following morning
they just gave up the land the same
thing in minnesota in minneapolis
they took over the city had we not
gotten the national guard
in there it was you would not have
minneapolis anymore it would have been
burned down to the ground
those are the ones you have to worry
about